do you see the [ __ ] police report on
jon jones i did not i'm out
i'm out there officially out i know she
ran out of the the hotel room with her
children covered in blood bloodies
bloody lips sweatshirts bloody and they
go did you did they did you know she's
protective man they go uh did he hit you
and she goes not really
like okay
and then you know you know why the cops
got called his daughter said because the
the wife was scared to go back to the
room she said can you give me another
key like i don't want to go back to room
i'm scared and the daughter goes can you
please call the cop oh no
how old is his daughter i don't know 13
12 now this is the youngest one i think
right
read that shit's like i'm out dude
i'm out officially out he had been a
police car well the uh originally he was
uh yeah that he was resisting the rest
and they said to the cops i'd love to
see you guys uh see how you guys would
do against me all of you at once i'm
like well sir you're gonna keep doing so
we're gonna tase you yeah so then i
guess he was going in and out like
crying and getting mad crying getting
max you know obviously he's clearly
[ __ ] and then when they handcuffed him
he headbutted the car so hard it put a
dent in it and chipped paint which is a
felony because you can't do that to a
police car so that's a felony i did not
know that and that oh yeah you can't
damage a police car so that's a felony
in las vegas
and then i don't know you know because i
don't because he got arrested for
domestic violence yeah but the i don't
think the wives can press charges
but then but there's there's blood like
they've seen you know they have all that
yeah it's a misdemeanor charge if she
doesn't press charges
the irony is it goes away
um i don't know if that's true
well because because if the
the kids go call the cops and she has
blood on she has a she has a busted lip
and there's blood on her she goes well
he just pulled my hair
because let's say
let's say i beat up cat in here right
now and then cat goes i'm not pressing
charges yeah but the cops came and katz
has bruised and [ __ ] yes it doesn't work
like that because they don't actually
see it uh so they would have to have
evidence the problem is that if she's
that's why they took his dna you know
that yes yes but the thing is if she
refuses to testify
you you would have a very hard time
following that through so now if we had
witnesses and we said i don't care what
she said the only witnesses would be the
kids right right and typically that's
another sketch sticky subject so my
guess is he
he moves on
and it's it's another
it's another we can figure out the the
felony on the cop car too i was i was
listening to daniel cormier talk about
this and cormier was saying
the guy has always been in trouble like
it's once it's mo yes we all know we can
have a moment and go crazy and you get
in a fight okay when you've been in
trouble
this often i think eight times nine
times yeah now the temptation to say
something like well it's cte or
something no that's not i don't know and
i know you top out i know you and i have
talked about that that's a complete
cop-out you and i a long long time ago
privately you know a lot about john you
know a lot about that world and
you know
the people that know him
are not surprised well she says once a
victim calls the police or someone else
calls the police to report domestic
violence the matter is out of the
victim's hand yeah
yeah
well so so even though she's going to
try to like no you have to get arrested
you get arrested the question is does it
does it is there a case a good lawyer
says there's no case here guys yeah and
a da's not going to pick that up or a
prosecutor is not going to pick that up
so here is the law enforcement officers
believe a crime was committed they will
arrest alleged offender regardless of
whether the victim wants to press
charges and that's from that's from
experience because what happens
typically is the woman says no it's okay
and then the guy kills her
yeah as soon as the cop leaves so it
says only the prosecutor can decide
whether to drop the charges that's right
and the prosecutor well in there to your
point judge may dismiss the charge
there's insufficient evidence
yeah
that's so much though there's so much
even there's witnesses at the
hotel that they're you saw her
but it happened in the room
i went this account of what
they were saying to him yeah they said
she was shaken saying yeah the kid
wanted to call the police so there's not
a thing where like i mean because
obviously she's probably she's in
something that's like messing with her
mentally and can't like fully make that
decision like
an officer or a judge can't go like
she's not in her right mind to like
really decide if this is a healthy
that's why they are arrested so that's
why they take them out of the house you
know so but that's why they arrest you
so if you if you call on a if you call
about somebody who's hitting you yeah
they will arrest that person so that
they give you like sort of that cooling
off period so nobody dies in the house
but sometimes like you you see these
situations and like
people don't realize they're in like
that hectic of a no she knows
yeah yeah but she knows
she's been in some [ __ ] for i think
they've been together 13 years yeah by
the way i don't think she's the first
time
well no we know it's not that yeah we do
know it's not yeah i mean the guy's been
in non-stop [ __ ] oh i believe you i mean
i mean yeah this you know cormier said
something interesting to me said the
guys the guy's done what he wants when
and how
and he's still a champion and he still
wins no the cormain made that you're
missing the but the key point there's
daniel cormier goes
if john would have if i would have beat
john i don't think he'd do this because
he would have to face himself in the
mayor right because he's acting like an
[ __ ] he's getting arrested but do you
have season there's no repercussions
from ufc there's no repercussions really
from the law think about that nothing's
happening he's still a millionaire and
there's still still he's still able i
disagree he's still able to compete and
dana cormier cormay's like if me or
chael or anybody would have beat him
he'd be like i got to stop doing this i
could get serious
but he you know he still wins yeah yeah
well so do you think now that he will be
kind of he won't fight in ufc again
i i i bet you dana's gonna wait to see
what they're gonna do as far as legally
yeah and then
if it's you know
bad or
he's out they're not gonna ride with him
anymore and he's being difficult you
know what i'm saying yeah does the ufc
need them i was gonna that's what i was
gonna say what's funny about all this
all of us and the entertainment they did
back in the day
is that
when jon jones goes away we'll all be
fine and we'll keep watching the ufc
we'll keep watching fighting it'll be a
whole maybe for a while
but it's not he hasn't fought in so long
and and still we're still watching we're
still talking about brian ortega we're
still talking about the other guys we
still want to see what francis and gano
and khan is no anybody could go away in
the uc keeps on keeping on and that's
the one thing same with the nfl you know
yeah this is what a samuel mma posted
that john posted after this
on his instagram i have way too much
trauma to consume alcohol my brain said
we can't handle anymore i believe
alcohol in my past forever turn this
nightmare into the best thing you ever
have in my life what the devil means for
bad god means for good get right back on
my horse now's the time to work hard
never how would you quit hitting your
[ __ ] wife dude how about that
how would you apologize to your wife and
kids
yeah i'm out man i'm out i used to ride
for the guy i'm out officially out
yeah the kids yeah the security they
call the cops
[ __ ] he's probably drunk probably coked
out of his mind
and and you know no excuse you know it
doesn't matter i know a lot of guys
drink coke and don't touch women or
scare their [ __ ] kids
and then he said oh i just grabbed her
by the hair
let me do that [ __ ] yeah
i just grabbed her
hi there what oh you're 270 pound man
the pound-for-pound graves fighter on
the planet you pulled your wife by the
hair
then how'd she get a fat lip
it's insane what's that thing in ozark
the [ __ ] that great opening scene in
ozarks uh that that show with jason
bateman
and uh he's like in my my maid you know
she stole from my family and she begged
and she said please and my father said
you have to go and i was like father
please give her another chance he goes
this isn't the first this first time she
got caught first time yeah
yeah if you if you've done that we know
we know
yeah i'm just wondering how much the ufc
is going to put up with it and then
you're talking about espn especially the
culture we live in now
it's going to get dicey for him for the
first time i think i think you're right
yeah i think you're right i don't know
and then also it's like oh my bad i'll
quit drinking alcohol it's like
but what about all the other [ __ ] dude
yeah it can't be just alcohol all the
time what about all the other [ __ ]
and then if you're the ufc like think
about it now you're going to put
together a fight let's say you fight
someone or francis and sarah gone
now you're going to do all this
promotion and bet on this guy to get a
[ __ ] together
you know
and how about dana this would hurt me so
bad if i was johnny goes it's a he goes
i'm not even surprised to expect it at
this point he goes we thought by flying
in for the big sign of his life on
getting into the hall of fame and we
could fly him out like we should but he
was usually if he's in vegas we get him
in and out because we know it's you know
he's like a gremlin after midnight we
can't have him here
he didn't say that i did
but he goes uh with the hall of fame he
goes he came with his wife and kids so
he thought he was good
yeah he's like i figured kids are good
but i guess they got in a fight because
he came back to the room after and was
getting ten thousand dollars cash
because you want to go to the strip club
well she was like well can you could you
not so i have a theory on that you set
him with his wife and kids what jon
jones is gonna do is he's going to
manufacture a fight jon jones is going
to get himself into a fight with his
wife so he has an excuse to go you can't
keep him there i think you're giving too
much credit i don't think he's asking
her what to do that's that poor woman i
i mean he just goes yeah but then but
then to deal with the guilt whatever
that is he's probably like you start a
fight just so you have a reason to get
out because otherwise no you're talking
about you have to see you're talking
about like regular al bundy nine to five
problems he's going [ __ ] i'm going to
i'm going to club and he's probably
hammering she's like whoa you're drunk
he's like yeah i'm just getting my cash
remember i'm going to strip club and
then it's you know true
underlying issues there and it's a
nightmare you think nightmare yeah
you said they've been good at 13 years
oh wow man it's like you had one
job one job no i mean who are his
handlers how how does he not have people
around can't handle him just being like
dude what are you doing
i mean you can't have numb nuts around
them you know
you couldn't handle them nobody could
handle them what are you going to do i
don't want to handle it i'm sure i could
give him some advice and i don't want to
handle it like that yeah he's too early
that's his problem yeah yeah especially
at his age right still doing this
34 34 oh he's my age gun to your head
this is a tough question is is
is he a sociopath
um
i i hate asking that question i really
do give me the definition of so we throw
that term around a lot let me see the
definition so somebody i think clearly a
narcissist there's that a person let me
see it a person whose personality
disorder manifests itself in extreme
antisocial
ah no no
yeah i'll be a sociopath is he just he's
just a complicated guy
you've trained with him you know him i i
don't know him that well i mean not to
you know i don't i wish i was you know
clinically uh
capable of diagnosing what he's you know
how they say people are bad he like they
go bad guy no i don't think he's bad
complicated guy with demons i don't
think he's a bad guy i think he is one
of the guys that fame and success went
to his head and turned him into what he
is now sure he was i knew him before all
this happened remember he was the
co-main event when i was the main event
against roy nelson okay and he was there
this was not that this was a different
john yeah he was such a positive guy now
he could have been just faking the funk
and could have been a piece of [ __ ]
before then i don't know but usually
yeah fame and money but let's but like
so my thing with him is this
he what are the what is the i don't have
a lot of friends well what is the
trouble he actually got into it's all
drug and co drug and alcohol related
every time do you know what i'm saying
am i wrong about that so in other words
he hit a roll up his [ __ ] just drunk and
high hit a woman in a car ran away
um what were the other things he's done
he got a wreck in his bentley's hometown
right had like girls in there again this
was every time it's been when he's on
yeah so in a way it might be that he's
got [ __ ]
you know substance of problems yeah yeah
and then that year ago though so we know
what happened today or not today but
recently but this is a year ago okay uh
so ufc john jones have arrested me back
on several charges all right uh may
2012 jones was involved in accident we
drove the current telephone pole in new
york in new york
jones was arrested driving under the
influence there you go pleaded guilty he
was not since any jail time said paid a
fine so there you go again no
consequences uh 2014 lead up to 178 uh
jones and dale carrera involved in
allocation during fight week uh two need
to be separated all right that doesn't
count please don't put that on this list
john was scheduled to fight uc1821 prior
he fights potted for
you know stuff okay don't put that on
the list john's threshos win riding high
when he again found himself in legal
trouble jones was arrested in
albuquerque new mexico after leaving the
scene of a hit-and-run jones was charged
with felony leaving the scene of a crime
they had a marijuana pipe all right one
of the victims he'd run pregnant woman
jones to himself the police 18 months of
probation and community service again
no consequences but so they don't look
at this history and go like like see he
was but he there was no there's no he
wasn't drunk in that when he hit that
lady it doesn't seem i think he was i
heard he was
it done on the
right because he ran away so remember
when he hit her he ran away and then
came back and he came back to get cash
and cash
2019 jones was charged with battery fund
claims a waitress that jones hit her and
salted her plead no contest charges
place on 90 day probation again no
consequences so now hold on the last few
years jones has had a fair share of
trouble with drug testing you'll see
failed i don't care about any of that uh
you know so a lot so it sounds to me
well i remember he got on there during
the pandemic he got a uh arrested for a
dui because he he was shooting a gun
i remember shooting a gun talking to him
in the morning yeah yeah it sounds to me
like he he has a an alcohol yes and you
guys know people right yes when they
drink they're just completely different
i know people like that yeah yeah
they're terrible so it's it seems to me
that if john isn't an alcoholic drug
addict he's an addict
yeah he's a way better person
yeah right
now now here's my other again i don't
like i don't
i think he likes to party he always has
and you know and i'm sure addiction has
an issue to do with it but
you know
to say it's alcohol drugs and ct i think
is a cop-out right i just think it's
just people get it
super happy and making bad decisions
like spending all their money but
they're not
hitting they're not hitting their wives
they're not you know doing from the
children yeah i mean what are we talking
about so in a way sometimes when you get
drunk it brings out
who you really really are yes right i
don't know man i don't know no it does
but but but even his like that post the
arrogance like that's all good man but
it's like it's not dude we're sick of
this [ __ ] yeah how about that how about
we don't give a [ __ ] if we fight again
how about that dude you were thinking
about that yeah we don't care man yeah
that's that's a good point
we do there's no consequences for him
and it shows you he posts that that
weird thing me like i'm just not gonna
drink alcohol man my brain doesn't do
well on it god is good devil is evil
yeah see it the next it's like what the
[ __ ] dude yeah do you not realize the
magnitude of what you did dude
hitting your wife right your children
are scared and they call the cops on you
it's insane
even for a cage fire dana's like yeah we
gotta see what happens there you know